Oh
the community of North Philadelphia is
so much more than the buildings that
Temple wants us to put up it's the
people that they are pushing out with
the statement it's the people that will
have their rents raised because the
stadium will definitely raise the cost
of living in the area
suppose Stadium will be right across the
street from Wall Street you see a
stadium here would be devastating for
not just me but everyone on this street
we would have to deal with traffic which
we're dealing with now trash which we're
dealing with man and the noise
they go to the link everything financial
wise is a pro for the link and they make
all the Commission money and they make
all the concession money so I think
financially it really hurts temple when
they have a football game there just
have to all stick together and try to
keep hope to keep this thing from Pam
try to keep our neighborhood in textile
to keep it the best we know we can